if you are somebody who tries to to
teach yourself
and and you want to maximize your
improvement you have to try things out
if you're unsure about
a certain way of playing right about
where
when you weaken your king or when you
make certain types of moves just try it
out right
you have to do a lot of experimentation
if you read the biographies of some of
the greatest
self-learners in history people like
thomas edison and
people who didn't have access to
you know instruction in great quantities
uh
what i think unifies them is the fact
that they
had the guts to experiment uh and and
fail
many many many times and derive the
lessons from their losses and their
failures
so that is my very firm opinion
on on how you should approach this
process of
understanding and finding your balance
and finding your style
[Music]
and i know that this is all very general
and
uh it's all well and good but i just
wanted to make that clear as we come now
come back
the server is back online so we can
continue playing is everybody ready to
continue
let's get that energy going we have been
playing the sicilian for the last couple
of games by popular demand
and we will continue to do so
okay so we faced this line a couple of
times already
what is the main flaw of playing bishop
c4 against the sicilian it's the fact
that we can play e6
at any moment uh and blunt the bishop
entirely now we don't have to play e6
immediately we can develop our knight
first
uh and i would say that it's better to
develop this knight over the other one
because if we develop the other one
first we might allow a little
nasty move e5 so let's actually develop
knight f6 we again we don't have to
hurry oh and f3
perfect so now we play e6 and not only
are we blunting the bishop but when we
play d5 we're killing two birds with one
stone
we're opening up the center which is
particularly good now that he's played
this move f3
okay um how should we continue our
development
and uh this speaks to the theme
that i just talked about which is that
not every development move
uh it has to be an eat option of a
vesuvius you can just
play normal development moves sometimes
and they don't have to be the most
active moves right and
uh the move that i'm referring to here
is either bishop e7 but let's play
bishop d7 i don't want him to take on c6
and ruin my pawn structure so i'm going
to recapture with the bishop
does that make sense we could have tried
d4 setting a trap
because if he well anyways i'll talk
about that later
um so i'm going to note this now this is
a very important moment
six bishop d7 okay
now once again uh we can make a very
standard development move and it isn't
the most active one but it's a pretty
effective one thank you dukeduk94
so what do we do how do we get out of
this pin
how do we absolve ourselves of this pen
here's two good moves
please reserve your questions for after
the game one is bishop b7
but there is a slightly spicier move
that we can play we can actually move
the queen
where can we move the queen i don't
particularly like queen a5
because it's too you know it's like
you're putting your head down and
barreling against the wall
let's play queen b6 what is the purpose
of this move first of all we're
attacking the pawn ring
second of all i am already eyeing this
diagonal
why am i eyeing this diagonal because
he's played f3
and by playing f3 he has weakened this
diagonal so
and perfect so we can now play a move to
make things explode
and this move is a direct consequence of
the fact that he played f3 and he
weakened this diagonal
this is a very standard kind of
breakthrough it looks
it may look mysterious but uh it's just
a
very direct conclusion uh of what he's
done it's it's a punishment
if you will c4 now we open up this
diagonal but that's not the only thing
we open up
he's probably going to take on c4 to
which we're going to respond
how what are we oh rook b1 is just too
slow
uh we can actually win material how can
we win material
think about all of the benefits of the
move c4 what have we opened up right
bishop before is correct
attacking this knife this knight lacks a
defender that is a pawn
and he can protect it with his other
knight but we can simply reinforce
the pressure on the knight with what
move we got d4
well okay he gives us the knight
immediately with check now he's got to
move the king it's a total disaster
let's recapture the pawn and now let's
chart of course
toward finishing the game this king is
on e2
that should immediately call to mind uh
the idea of
what what should be the total what
should be the idea
and what is the best way to accomplish
this idea
long castle is correct very good and
everybody sees it
we don't recon there's okay rookie 8 i
don't even ask people because that's
clear that you guys understand the idea
here
now after the king moves we want to open
up as many files as possible so we're
then going to play d take c4 but the
point is not to like
restore equality of pawns the point is
just to open up as many files as
possible and diagonals
and speaking of diagonals there is a
diagonal that we can open
and we can put a bishop on that diagonal
and basically checkmate him
so if we assume the queen moves to c1
which is the only possible square
i'm anticipating that he's either well
though okay so what do we do now
what do we do now
okay now we just take the queen and
uh the rest is very simple let's just
infiltrate with our queen potentially to
e2
and well i just got to make sure people
are paying attention and the game is
over
very simple direct
and the rest is just going to be history
so
he was already very much lost but if he
had moved to screen perhaps we would
have been able to demonstrate an
instructive move
he's disconnected okay so i think he
might have
you know might have gone his own way
here
okay and he
disconnects so we're over 1250 let's
play one more game here
or actually two more and we are black
against as as the
zero let's see let's go another sicilian
and he goes knight c3 as well thank you
uh j root for another 500 bits now
knight f3 we can go
g6 essentially preparing for the
accelerated and he goes d3
that's not a mistake but it's not a very
good move because
he blunts his bishop and the only way to
make d3 really work
would be g3 transposing into a king's
indian attack but probably he's gonna go
bishop e2
because i just have a feeling yep
uh and well that's just
very passive i mean there's there's very
very passive
uh and he keeps the center closed which
is fine
uh but we've got very harmonious
development we've got a nicely fiance
bishop that's sort of controlling and
skewering the whole diagonal
and uh he goes knight d5 so do we take
the knight
do we take the knight
yeah speedrun that is actually a slow
run
uh yes we do we absolutely do because we
ruin this pawn structure
and then where do we put this knight
yeah knight p4 exactly so we attacked
the pawn on d5 and
in fact it's a double attack we went
upon and
we just dropped the bishop back to g7
that's another thing that
okay so here we have a really cute move
if people want a five head move
try to find the best square for the
night and
really think deeply about where the
knight actually can go
think about all of the weak squares in
white's position yeah you guys are
actually seeing it
it's the move knight a2 which looks
incredibly scary like
isn't the knight gonna get trapped well
it's not because he cannot stop our
knight
from getting to c3 okay and he's not
attempted to he just blundered his rook
in response
that's actually one of the positive
byproducts of a move like knight a2 is
it
it it shocks the opponent uh and and
oftentimes
a blunder like this happens as a
consequence
uh that's actually in its option and he
resigns uh very good
okay so we're playing grand 25
and we have been playing the italian but
let's for some variety play the rye
lopez let's play the red lopez
he's played the bird and the bird is one
of those openings that that
makes a lot of people scared but the
reality is we should just play naturally
right first we should take the knight
and what is the most natural move uh in
this position just
the most natural no you're not
reinventing the wheel
not doing anything crazy or just
castling right
even the move d3 right so so he goes c6
now where should we put this bishop what
would be the most
um active i would say square for this
bishop
given that we're retreating that would
obviously be c4 yeah
he goes b5 big whoa right we don't care
uh
pawns alone are not going to win the
game and this is actually already a very
big mistake
if we look very carefully he forgot to
make one very important move
which is the move d6 and he's allowed us
to push up our own pawn
attack his knight he's going knight d5
but that is just asking for it
for what reason i mean
i'm not big on pawn structure but you
know
that's not to say pawn structure isn't
important we just take the knight i mean
queen f3 is not even necessary
look at his pawns he's got triple puns
uh but let's again not forget about
development let's not forget about the
eye response
uh let's not forget about the fact that
we have to
develop our queen side and we have to do
it quickly
we have a very fine okay we want to use
twitch terminology we have a very five
head way of developing this bishop on c1
think about what we want to accomplish
right the weakest of these three pawns
is the d4 pawn
can we use the bishop to attack that
pawn
can we use the bishop to attack that
pawn like do we have to develop this
bishop to f4 or can we find a more
creative way to develop it
yes we can there's something called the
fianchetto
okay uh he has started to move his
bishop back and forth all right that's
great
uh we fianchetto we win the pawn that
was weird
did i just hallucinate did he just go
bishop b7 bishop see he's having an
attemptron right now
i think he's having any toughness
yeah i know i'm making one easy blah
blah blah and now where should we put
this knight well we only have one square
which is c3 that is a fork
we're going to take d5 and we're going
to win the game
okay there should be some now i'm going
to say something
radical right now we don't actually even
need to take this one
right we don't need to take this point
why the hell
not like what what is it that we can do
that is that is
better than taking a free pawn
what do you guys think
e6 i don't want to open the position up
e6 would be a very instructive mistake
actually
uh but the move queen g4 i really like
because it accumulates
the attacking chances on the queen on
the king's side
it accumulates attacking chances on the
king side now
the queen of the bishop alone are not
going to deliver the checkmate e6 would
be very very tempting i know
but then black can go f6 and he can
essentially blunt
the influence of the bishop so what
we're going to do is play f4
we are preparing exactly two things
first is a rook lift which i really like
the second is just a pawn push all the
way to f6 and then we're going to
deliver lobster pins are made on g7
both of these ideas are competing for
our attention and they're both very
strong
the fastest is just to try to ram this
pawn up to f6
okay to his credit he's defending well
but let's bring another piece into the
game let's bring the rook into the game
and what i want to emphasize in
positions like this
is is that we're not actually in a hurry
there's no
need to go crazy there's no need to go
for checkmate within
three four moves because uh not only are
we better tactically we are attacking
but we are also better positionally we
are
dominating him in terms of blockading
the d4 square let's open up the position
and we have after bishop takes f6
another very five head move
we have a move that crushes instantly
and it's a very very nice move and
how do i find this move well i see that
the bishop on f6 is immobilized it
cannot move back
so we play rook to e7 bishop cannot
capture the rook because of checkmate
right and that's how i saw this move i
saw that the bishop was immobilized
if he takes on d4 and we take with a
queen repositioning it but we're still
threatening checkmate
he has to go rook f7 and after he goes
rook f7
okay goes for cuff 6. my first
inclination well i have several
inclinations uh we can resort back to an
idea that we had earlier
what is that idea that we had earlier
which may allow us to increase
our attacking um potency oh yeah we can
just play knight 65 actually that's a
that's actually even better
uh and that's not just a pawn that's
also a fork against his
uh kang and his rook and i guess he
could play king fade and try to
counter attack our rook and
uh what would be the simplest win here
and this is where we talk about
transforming the advantage right most
people
would be inclined to take on d7 but
whenever there are two pieces hanging
you want to check what happens
if you take one of the pieces queen
takes eight eight
if you calculate with me king takes e7
we're going to play this move
we can give a check on e1 and the king
has to emerge out of its shell
because if he goes king f7 and i think
that's what he might actually do
uh he allows no he plays correctly but
now we take on a6 we hunt him down
and again we transform the advantage if
he offers us a queen troop king
king c5 let's continue the king hunt
what should we do
how do we continue the king hunt can we
give a check
that further brings his king out of the
shell let's go b4 check
okay and this is not rocket science we
could have also considered d4 check
uh and king hunting is hard
uh but it's not like i know something
that you don't i'm just trying to find
the right way to funnel the king in the
right direction if you will now i'm
gonna go c4
uh threatening queen d5 checkmate uh and
if he gives us a check on a7
we can counter with check of our okay
queen e5 this checkmate
um i went quickly through that segment
uh just because there's no
no there's no rocket science there i'm
just sort of bringing attackers in
that was a nice game uh and and this
game really illustrates the concepts
of transforming the advantage and
purposeful development all in sort of
one package
one more game then we analyze then we
wrap up for today it's already been six
hours actually so i'm getting really
really tired but
one more game i've got in me and this
time he goes b6 we've already faced
g6 uh this time we're facing b6 oh no
board okay sorry sorry sorry
our conception from the last time
somebody played g6 against us
what move did we discuss at length
in that game and that was the move h4 so
let's play h4 let's see what he does
and i guarantee you that this is going
to win us the game he allows us
to ram our pawn all the way up to h5
which is
actually quite devastating quite quite
devastating
and what are we threatening uh once
again let us review
by playing h5 well there is one thing we
can do
that i indicated earlier which just uh
h6 right exactly we just push harry down
the board
the bishop has a very unenviable choice
of
retreat squares you can go to f8 or we
can go to f6
and both of these moves are just
incredibly ugly they both have their
drawbacks
once again he has combined the two
forbidden moves e6 and g6
and by just simply developing eventually
we're going to control
all of these dark squares and that is
going to be the instrument of our
domination
now here i'm going to actually on
poisson i want to keep the center a
little bit open
uh now you guys might be very surprised
by this move right why are you giving up
that e pawn which was controlling f6
and part of the reason that i'm doing it
is because the h6 pawn is already
controlling enough dark squares
we don't need another pawn controlling
the dark squares around blind skiing we
have one and that's enough
but let's continue expanding in the
center let's continue
ramming pawns up his throat uh and
creating weaknesses
in his position what move am i talking
about here indirectly
i'm talking about the move d5 advancing
the pawn opening up the center blah blah
he's probably going to go e5 but when he
goes e5 we re
we reassess the situation we ask
ourselves okay which new weak squares
have been created as a consequence
and the square that i'm really that
catches my eye is this square on c6
can we try to get a piece there can we
try to get a piece to the c6 square
and we re we can i mean it's a pretty
simple idea
we can try let's give a check on b5
let's see what he does
all right there we go we got a we got a
bishop to c6 okay he's taken which is
just basically
harakiri because by taking on c6 and
this is something a lot of beginners
fail to do
uh is is i understand the sort of
positional
ramifications of a trade right and he's
going to
well he i was going to say he's going to
win the policy six but he's actually
not going to win the pawn on c6 because
we are going to defend it
how are we going to defend it with the
queen
okay queen c7 and now it is time to look
at tactics
how do we know to look for tactics here
well we've got a lead in development
he's got
tons of weaknesses we've talked about
these situations before
uh this is just calling for tactics
knight b5 is going to be the move
uh because once he takes we're going to
go knight c7 check
we could have taken the queen first and
then played knight c7 but i want to keep
the queens on the board
this guy is actually very good uh he's
playing a lot better than his rating
uh so kudos to him we're just gonna keep
developing
now we are going to extricate our queen
from
uh a8 we're going to slam it on d5 where
it is
sitting on a very nice outpost he goes
queen c6 now
we can trade queens that's fine but
let's trade queens
on our terms what do i mean by that
let's trade queens on our terms what
move keeps the tension
while also developing and while also
uh applying pressure on one of his
weaknesses that would be long castle
exactly all right now training is boring
but sometimes it's necessary and if he
trades queens
you know be my guest he allows our rook
then to occupy this outpost
pawn on d6 is hanging and now it's clear
that our plan should revolve around
attacking that pawn on d6 how do we
go about attacking that pawn on d6 what
pieces do we use it's clear that we'll
need to use our knight
where should we put our knight in order
to exert pressure
on d6 knight d2 is correct i see a lot
of people indicating this
thank you nickelodeon for the thousand
bits this is a maneuver that people may
see and think
what is it that's a classic gm move it's
not really a gm move it's very simple
you're just
identifying the biggest weakness and
thinking about how you can attack it
more purposefully and uh minor pieces
are very good at that okay he just
leaves that pawn hanging so we're just
gonna take it okay great i mean he
trades and
lets us activate our king that's perfect
and don't forget about this pawn on h6
mark my words
that pawn is going to be precisely the
reason why we win the game other than
the fact that we're up in exchange
okay so what remains in this position
well we need to activate
all of our pieces which means the stroke
on h1 needs to be activated
as efficiently as possible and there is
a perfect way of doing that there's
several
can somebody give me an elegant way of
activating the stroke
we can actually rook yeah we can do a
rook lifts
uh don't think of rook lifts as only
things that happen
in attacking middle games we can lift a
rook up in order to activate it i mean
nobody forbade us to do that
yep there we go rook c7 and
um we have a and what did i tell you
guys i told you mark my words we're
going to use the h6 bond to win the game
and i didn't know how we're going to do
that it did i didn't know if it would be
checkmate
and the time has come to use the h6 pawn
to win the game we can take on g6
and if he takes our pawn actually
promotes which is kind of ironic we
thought we might use the pawn to give
checkmate
but we actually use this pawn to make a
new queen out of it
and that's why long-term weaknesses
like a pawn on h6 are so hard to deal
with because they're
they're there forever uh and and they
can
transform themselves into so many
different other advantages
all right so we're going to win this
game the rest is
very simple we just use the queen to
pick off
as many pawns as possible and then we
promote the resulting passers
okay let's create a pass pawn we already
know from
many uh many of these cases that the
basic
winning formula in such positions is to
create a passpond as efficiently as
possible and then to push it all the way
to
promotion okay he's giving up the knight
the rest is easy
we're just gonna push the spot up
through to ga we're going to make a
second queen
and we're going to use the two queens to
ladder checkmate
okay i mean i'm not actually a
specialist in finding the fastest mate
oh yeah this is me
okay um that was a nice game
uh and and he played very very well now
this 13 move game
the only thing to point out is that uh
the accelerated dragon also offers a
very good setup for people
uh to play against almost any uh of
these
setups that white may have right you
don't really need to change the way that
you play with black
now this move knight a2 is one that i
wanted to explain
why is the knight not getting trapped
because we have the c3 square
and that is where the bishop comes into
play the bishop controls that square
and white has no way of controlling it
twice right
um so that was a very simple game and he
flutters his rook
and that's not the only time that the
move knight a2 won a game
for me on the 12th move i actually had a
game
many years ago where the move knight a2
won me the game in 13 moves oh my god
that's a pretty eerie coincidence
so this game took 13 moves now look at
this game
that i played many years ago over the
board
richard newey against me in 2007 i was
2100
very similar opening he played this
bishop e2
he does this weird stuff with b4 he
opens up the diagonal
and now look at this knight on b4
i don't just drop it back to c6 tamely
where do i put my knife
boom knight a2 and he resigned because
this knight
essentially is the instrument of the
knight on c3's demise
yeah so i was actually
11 when this game was played yeah
but um yeah so 13 moves and the move
knight a2 was featured in it that's a
pretty interesting set
in this other in this next game he
played the bird variation of the rye
lopez
forgot to play d6 so we play e5 we
shatter his pawn structure use the dark
squared bishop to pick off the pawn
and then slowly accumulate the pressure
this move rookie 7
is where the party is at right we're
using the fact that this bishop on f6 is
basically immobilized it cannot
move from this diagonal because of the
possibility of checkmate
and uh the rest is is relatively
straightforward we want another pawn we
get the king out we want to third pawn
we hung the fourth pawn and then we
delivered checkmate
um and in the last game we again
successfully employed the move h4 now
probably
black should still play h5 this is the
lesser evil
uh even though he does weaken t5 my
guess
and this is actually a line i mean
people play this stuff with black i
don't like it personally and partially
because of it you'll see me playing h4
against other gms
right i'm not trying to peddle stuff
that that's somehow
you know very dubious i'm telling you
stuff that i would do myself
thank you uh even that's very sweet
uh and uh it's great to be appreciated
so he allowed us to push the spawn all
the way to h6 push harry up all the way
to h6
and notice what we're doing here we're
not we're not following up with g4 or
anything like that we're just developing
our pieces because the pawn on h6
is perfectly well defended he's got no
way
to reinforce his attack on the h6 pawn
and we play e5 we take the pawn we go d5
we continue to expand in the center
create weaknesses that he
uh allows us to create more weaknesses
from right now we go upon def
queen to d5 uh and and these weaknesses
start multiplying
eventually transform transforming
themselves into a tactic
right so this entire game was decided
basically
by weak squares and these weak squares
eventually allowed
us to transform them into a direct
tactical sequence okay
um can black also develop the knights f6
yeah so that's something to consider
but the move e5 here would be quite
problematic that's why
not having any of the central bonds out
could be dangerous
because here black must again allow h5
if he tries knight h5
uh well then the knight is on the rim
and that creates its own set of problems
um so so i'm not sure that this would be
a long-term solution for black
okay so once yeah once the spawn reached
h6 the funny thing is if we fast forward
all the way to the end
first of all in the end game if you want
tips
about the end game piece activity is
crucial you want all of your pieces to
be active okay and if there's
one piece that is not doing anything in
the end game that's a pretty bad sign
that's why we lifted the rook up all the
way to c7
then you look at pawns that may
potentially become past pawns
and you try to make a note of them right
this h6 pawn is far advanced
far advanced pawns are important in the
end game because with material being so
limited
it is much harder simply mathematically
speaking to stop pawns from promoting
okay and so that is why i found the
mover of takes g6 because i realize that
this pawn is two steps away from
promotion
if we can dislodge this h7 pawn then our
pawn is going to promote and if he
doesn't take on g6 well then we are
going to forcibly remove the h7 pawn
and promote our own pawn after that
uh but but but hopefully that was
satisfactory for
for now i think i'm going to go now and
sleep for a couple of hours
so but i just wanted to say how much i
appreciate
uh and whoa man i'm i'm getting bribed
500 bits by travman
curious chimpanzee with 100 bits uh and
another thousand bids by phineas gage
uh and encore is called for uh given
this incredible uh support that we've
had today
um all right fine fine well especially
because people are continuing to bribe
me
smoke brandon subbing with switch prime
we have ob 68 with 100 bits
uh man this hype train has rocketed out
of the station bologna bolognese at tier
one
another hundred bits by j root holy
smokes
all right let's get that game on the
road
we are playing 1287 hmhk
all right let's go c5 and let's get
another uh
sicilian and we've been playing the
sicilian for the last couple of games
and now we play g6 i'm gonna disable the
alerts just for this game
thank you drunky skunky okay so we
already know
that we're not afraid of him taking on
c6 and can somebody remind me
how did we decide to capture the last
time and for what reason thank you for
the 100 bits modern algebra
what what is the the recapture that i
like yes so we played dc
uh now i know most people want to
capture toward the center but we open up
the bishop and we're gonna basically do
the exact same thing trapman gifting
five
trav man 9 25 5 gifted subs
this is incredible now where should this
knight from g8 go can somebody
illustrate for me
the general plan that black has here and
we literally had the same position a
couple of games ago
so this is a perfect perfect way to
cement our understanding we play 97
and our idea is to push f5 and expand on
the king's side
eventually transforming that into an
attack on white's king
first we're gonna castle okay he's
probably gonna play bishop okay bishop
g5
now we don't want to play f5 immediately
let's first chase away the bishop and
see where it goes
okay well he takes the knight great
we'll just take back we've got two
bishops against two knights that's a
pretty damn good deal
uh and we are ready to play f5 let's go
f5 he's probably gonna take it and then
we're gonna take back with the pawn
and again the same litmus test that i
recommended we can use here
does he have a lot of pieces on the
king's side
not really right he's got a lot of
pieces clustered in the center
but they're all sort of awkward they're
not enough
to constitute any real pressure on my
center because my
own uh well my own
pieces are nicely clustered in the
center particularly the bishops
uh and you can see by the move knight h2
that white is
starting to fold over a little bit now
where should we now
continue our development what should we
do and let's be calm here no
need for anything crazy let's just
complete our development and that's
kind of the theme of the first half of
the speed run almost is is
you know despite an unbalanced position
we just continue adhering to general
principles
some people are saying bishop d7 i'm
going to develop it to e6 i feel like
it's a little bit more active
and the bishop from g7 is actually doing
a great job
supporting that pawn on e5 f3
that is a very ugly move now what
exactly makes it ugly well as we already
know
the main thing that makes a move like f3
ugly not to mention the knight on h2
being locked out
is the fact that it opens up this
diagonal
the a7 g1 diagonal to be exact
and to show you guys the sort of
algorithm of thinking
we can actually make a semi-tactical
move
that immediately exposes the
uh sort of erroneousness of of this move
f3
the error behind we can play c4 this is
actually a typical idea
in these kinds of sicilian lines
although
we don't always play c4 because this
diagonal is weak and how do we follow up
with this move queen c5 we can even play
queen b4 by the way
green b4 is also possible uh but this is
the the sort of the clinical way
check we will take the pawn back and
because the position is open up this
benefits the bishops
he uh is at risk of losing exchange
and if he plays queen f2 which is the
only way to save an exchange why does it
save the exchange
uh because uh it it counter attacks
our queen and if we take his queen that
the same rook that is being attacked
takes our rook but there's a very five
head move here
okay and the concept that
uh essentially brings that essentially
brings this move out
is what i call trading on our own terms
trading on our own terms we want to find
a move
such that when he takes on c5
we make some sort of specific
improvement to our positioning
everybody finds bishop f8 i love to see
it bishop f8 is what i had in mind
there were several other ways we could
do that we could have also slid our
queen to b6
so then when he takes it we open up that
a file for our rook
that would have also been a very
interesting way to trade on our own
terms this is exactly what i mentioned
when i said keeping the tension that is
very hard to do
people are uncomfortable when they do it
but it reaps
tremendous benefits if you do it
properly now what should we do here
because the window of opportunity for
the queen trade has
passed but now we can take the queen
we take the queen and how can we follow
up what should we do
what are the next two moves that we make
here in order to fully activate
all of our pieces and i want a chorus of
people saying this
bishop c5 is right first first and
foremost we attack the rook send it back
so that the other bishop pins it and
then we have
one more piece to activate that would be
the rook and we are going to send
that rook over to d2 to collect
a bunch of the puns or perhaps just the
knight now again
our opponent okay very good here's what
i hate
i hate looking at this bishop and saying
this bishop is locked
out this bishop has to join in on the
action this is not fair
how how do we make sure this bishop
joins in on the yeah let's crash through
his defenses he doesn't have enough
pieces
to hold this measly wall
this pawn on c4 in place i suppose he
can play rook c1
uh but that would tie his rook down to
the defense of the pawn now this guy is
again
i'm playing some very underrated folks
let's get the rook to d2
and uh i'll concede to him
that he has he has succeeded in keeping
my bishop out of this diagonal
but that's what makes bishops so strong
they're very resilient
and they're able to reposition
themselves very very quickly so
uh he's got knight g3 he's attacking the
pawn how do we simultaneously defend the
pawn and reposition our bishop
to greener pastures where should we put
that bishop
we go no f4 weakens a lot of squares be
very careful about the move f4
f4 is very tempting i understand that
but when you push a pawn
you always want to understand what
weaknesses it creates now we go king f7
to stop a fork on f6
the bishop is going to reposition itself
to e6 to keep the rook tied down
f4 is pretty useless because we just
push
the pawn with e4 his position has begun
to crumble
look at how throughout the whole game
his knights are just stuck
essentially on the h file doing nothing
let's complete
our repositioning bishop e6 now we have
to ask ourselves okay what is going to
be the subsequent plan of action
first of all we can collect some of the
hanging pawns right we can take on a2
but i don't even want to take on it i
want to extend our domination completely
and again
the concept of trading on our own terms
how do we make sure
that we trade on d2 on our own terms
there's two good possible ways of doing
that the first
is rook eda which a lot of people are
suggesting
the second is what we are going to do
which is e3
this kills two birds with one stone
simultaneously we push our
past pawn and we prepare to push it even
further when we recapture our rook
this is something that we have to do
with a granite okay so rook
here now look at this knight for a
second
this knight is actually very vulnerable
and we're going to attack it by playing
rook g8
and if the knight moves then the g2 pawn
is at risk of falling
he does have 92 however okay goes in
that f1
let's take on a2 and i'm going to
accelerate the speed of my play a little
bit because
we're short of time but the hard work
has already been done
and now all that remains is the easy
work he's played knight takes e3
what is the problem with this move
nobody worry guys
i will win this game i just want
somebody to tell me what the issue of
this move is
he blunders the knight on g3 the game is
essentially over because now
he's got to move the knight again and
then
the chain reaction basically starts okay
so now we take here look at how both
rooks are hanging so if he takes one
rook i take the other
and this is where the real daniel
neridisky shows up
and just give me a second guys i want to
make sure i don't lose on time
okay so this is why i told you i will
not flag and i promise
for this reason okay let's take off the
mask
we've shown up to the party this is
checkmate uh
but in any case i i knew that it might
seem like i'm cutting it close but the
reality is
at that point the position was already
winning uh
and and that was a great game i mean
that was a very rich very rich game
uh full of sort of interesting
tension okay um
maybe i should threaten to leave again
we're almost 1300 that was our goal
when we began this part of the speed run
and we are already at a level where we
are beginning to play serious people uh
people who know what they're doing who
have
plans who don't blunder often uh and i
know that for some of you that's
pretty exciting ones okay um
now just to quickly go over the game
basically the smooth dc i want people to
understand that
things like capture toward the center
right
yes that is a valuable principle and
most of the time you should adhere to it
but here we're playing dc because i want
to open up the bishop
and it's not that i really need another
prawn in the center right the movie five
is
plenty good enough we have these two
pawns exerting this
bind over the d4 square and now we
execute
the sort of traditional plan of playing
f5
now if he plays a move such as rook add1
and i want to illustrate through the
lens of this move
black's main idea what does black do
can somebody tell me what black's move
is and what the long-term plan is
those of you who play the king's indian
should have a pretty easy time
borrowing extrapolating that plan to
this position because
the fundamental idea here is very much
i would say the same we actually play
thank you so much trav man a huge shout
out to that guy
uh for a total of 70
gifted subs today uh incredible
incredible stuff
and the support was absolutely unreal
and also 5
500 bits so that was awesome
okay the move is f4 we lock up the
center
why do we lock up the sub when we lock
up the center it becomes easier to
attack
on the side of the board now we're going
to start attacking on the king side
we're going to do that by essentially
just pushing up our pawns
very slowly very surely that is why
knights are just
so bad they're not able to make anything
happen on the other side of the board
because we've put our pawns on squares
such that
he cannot open up the center and look at
the pawn on c5 it is a trooper
it's stopping d4 and it's also
controlling the b4 square making it very
hard for white
to make any sort of counterplay on the
other side of the board
okay so this is essentially what black's
plan would be
i'm too tired right now to illustrate
exactly how this would unfold
but hopefully people can fill in the
blanks and in the in the game
he played this move f3 and immediately
he weakens this diagonal we play c4
queen c5 bishop c4 and the rest is just
very simple
there were two instances here of trading
on our own terms
the first was this one bishop f8 right
we want to simultaneously deploy our
bishop
and trap his rook we don't just
willy-nilly take the queen
the second instance of trading on our
own terms look at b5
either we get our bishop back into the
game or
as happened in the game we tie his rook
down to the defense of a
measly pawn and then again in this
position trading on our own terms
e3 right take my rook absolutely be my
guest
but guess what there's a price debate
for that that price
is that you get this pawn all the way to
d2 now we put bishop takes c4 rookie one
and we take on f1 so that is how
effective it is really to think about
trading on different terms
now we identify hanging pieces we see
that knight on g3 is undefended
blah blah blah we take the knight we
take the knight again
uh and and and look at this situation
where both rooks are hanging if he takes
one rook we take the other one
that's actually a pretty common
situation and the rest is
essentially checkmate all right so that
was basically this game was a pretty
well thought out game
and i think that that was a fitting
encore
uh to i think a really really good run
of course
one could argue that we are within 17
points of 1300 so it would make sense
to stick around and achieve 1300 but
i think that everything must come to an
end we have to be patient
there will be more opportunities for the
speedrun so
i think we had a productive session um
sleep does sound like a very good option
right now uh
i might make my way to the couch and uh
sleep to the tune of the tv
but yeah uh again the
[Music]
support today has been incredible this
is an epic stream
uh and the last time i said this we had
another outboard of support so
i might never end up leaving but i think
this time i will actually go to sleep
so thank you guys so much that is always
in i always like to be bribed but
this time i'm going to going to sleep
for sure it's 5 am
i need some shedding